Один усе життя присвятив політиці, другий - досягненню комерційних зисків.
Годі собі уявити більш несхожих між собою кандидатів та більш контрастні політичні програми, ніж у Байдена і Трампа.
Надія вище, ніж страх. Єдність вище, ніж поділ. Наука вище, ніж фантастика. І правда - вище брехні.
Ці вибори - вибір між відновленням Трампа на найвищому рівні та депресією Байдена.
Контраст між двома кандидатами простежується і в українському питанні.
У разі перемоги Джо Байдена на виборах 3 листопада президентом стане політик з глибокими знаннями про Україну.
Байден опікувався українським напрямком в адміністрації Обами,
коли Росія анексувала Крим та коли почалася війна на Донбасі.
На його рахунку - 6 візитів до України в часи віцепрезидентства.
Дозвольте сказати з максимальною ясністю: Сполучені Штати не визнають
і ніколи не визнають спроби Росії анексувати Крим!
На противагу Байдену, Дональд Трамп запам‘ятався своєю слабкою позицією щодо Росії
та відсутністю слів підтримки для України.
Він напряму не засудив російську агресію.
Володимира Путіна називає не диктатором чи агресором, а "шахістом світового класу".
У Трампа своєрідна чоловіча дружба з Путіним. Він бачить у Путіні сильного чоловіка.
І він отримує задоволення, перебуваючи в його компанії.
Я не думаю, що Джо Байден матиме подібні думки. У нього буде жорсткий підхід до Росії.
Це вкрай необхідно.
Берлінський політолог Йорґ Форбріґ нагадує, що у своїй першій каденції президент Трамп
поставив під питання доцільність існування НАТО.
Ще один президентський термін Трампа може остаточно поховати трансатлантичний Альянс.
З Байденом прогнозують відновлення зруйнованої Трампом тісної взаємодії між США та Європою.
А від солідарності західної спільноти непрямо матиме зиск і Україна.
Не секрет, що політика Заходу останніх років щодо України в багатьох аспектах була не особливо ефективною.
Не врегульований ані конфлікт на Донбасі, не зроблено значного поступу в реформах у самій Україні.
Багато що з цього є тривожним. Тому більша згуртованість Заходу,
жорсткіша і солідарніша позиція щодо Росії мала б позитивні наслідки для України
та вирішення конфліктів на її території та процесу реформ.
Те, що США за президентства Трампа продовжили надавати військову підтримку Україні
та навіть розширили її за рахунок летальної зброї, експерти вважають не стільки заслугою Трампа,
скільки результатом згоди республіканців та демократів у цьому питанні.
Також експерти упевнені, що Байден буде прибічником надання Україні озброєнь на відміну від Барака Обами.
У мемуарах Джо Байдена є кілька фрагментів, присвячених Україні.
Він пише, що він намагався переконати Барака Обаму забезпечити Україну протитанковими ракетами "джевелін"
та іншим військовим обладнанням, щоб ефективніше відбивати атаки росіян.
Тож, я щиро вірю в те, що в разі президентства Байдена буде продовжуватися військова підтримка
та постачання озброєнь, які за президента Трампа надавалися Україні.
Тому що це дуже необхідно для стабільності України та відсічі російської агресії.
Слід зауважити, що Байдена і Трампа з Україною поєднує один великий скандал.
У липні 2019 року Дональд Трампу телефонній розмові попросив тоді новообраного президента України
Володимира Зеленського розслідувати роль Байдена у звільненні українського генпрокурора Віктора Шокіна у 2016 році.
Трамп припустив, що це звільнення було пов'язане з розслідуванням проти газовидобувної компанії Burisma,
членом ради директорів якої був син віцепрезидента - Хантер Байден.
Через цей скандал Україна навіть стала однією з тем передвиборчих дебатів між кандидатами.
Експерти прогнозують, що через такі звинувачення Байден буде вкрай обережним у всьому, що стосуватиметься України.
Але у великих питаннях, таких як окупація Криму та війна на Донбасі, позиція Байдена чітка.
Тим часом Трампу, вважають експерти, "Українагейт" коштував більше, ніж Байдену.
І хоча під час спроби імпічменту Трампа виправдали, це може мати наслідки для Києва.
Зрештою усі сходяться на тому, що передбачити Трампа неможливо.
І його курс щодо Росії та України може несподівано змінитися.